Pizza Hawaii ist umstritten schreibt mir
in die Kommentare ob Ihr es mögt oder
nicht ich
äh klar wenn ich jetzt nach Zacke stramm
nach Hause komme und dass das einzige
ist was im Kühlschrank liegt natürlich
esse ich das aber so eine süße Ananas
auf einer Pizza
ich frage mich wahrscheinlich warum ich
euch das hier gerade erzähle
das Spiel was wir heute spielen heißt
pineapple und Pizza und das Spiel ist
mindestens genauso kontrovers wie Pizza
Hawaii
[Musik]
ich gehe mal ganz kurz hier zum Meer wo
die Musik ein bisschen leiser ist
das ist kein Apple und Pizza steht da
oben eine auf dem Berg ich habe keine
Ahnung worum es bei diesem
[Musik]
ich habe keine Ahnung worum es bei
diesem Spiel geht aber
[Musik]
irgendwie hat jeder hier gute Laune ist
komplett am updatessen
[Musik]
mach mal die Musik erstmal aus wir
schauen uns die ganze Insel erstmal mit
normaler Musik an
kann sich irgendwie nur ein bisschen
besser bewegen ach du scheiße
[Musik]
aber die haben alle super super gute
Laune
[Musik]
ich schwöre ich habe kein Joint geraucht
oder bin voll oder was weiß ich was es
ist einfach nur sehr unterhaltsam sich
diese Leute anzuschauen die einzige
Sache die ich auch übrigens machen kann
ist das hier
[Musik]
das einzige was ich machen kann ist
das
ich kann mich nur hinsetzen ich habe
keine Ansicht ich habe keine Beine wenn
ich an mir runter gucke ich kann nicht
sprinten ich kann nicht springen ich
kann nichts machen ich kann nur zack
und was ist das
[Musik]
ich würde allerdings sagen wir verlassen
diese Statue da vorne jetzt erstmal und
laufen hier so ein bisschen um die Insel
rum hier haben wir auch noch ein paar
Leute die tanzen jeder hat irgendwie so
seinen eigenen dance move die hier
machen so und gehen dann zur Seite rüber
machen dann die andere Hand und gehen in
die Richtung also jeder hat so irgendwie
Fortnite dances durchgespielt da vorne
sind auch noch welche am Tag oh das
sogar jemand in der Mitte sehe ich
gerade
[Musik]
ich mache die Musik wieder aus hier sind
die Boote und in See zu stechen
kann ich aber auch nichts machen ich
kann noch nicht auf so ein ich kann so
ein Bruder ich kann doch nicht drücken
Sie Standard Tasten nur mit irgendwas
interagieren bei Computerspielen
eigentlich hier vorne sind auch wieder
Leute am Tanzen sie hier ist allein am
Tanzen die Vögel da vorne sind hoch
geflogen sie ist am Tanzen
[Musik]
ich habe irgendwie ein bisschen Schiss
vor dieser Wolke da gerade ne
die Vögel sind weggeflogen
die Wolke kommt hier an
aber gut egal gute Laune hier vorne
tanzen so weiter um so ein Busch rum ich
weiß jetzt auch gar nicht was irgendwie
das Ziel von diesem Spiel ist ne guck
mal hier vorne wird den wird angepflanzt
was haben wir denn hier Blumenkohl haben
wir am Stein ich will jetzt nicht
durchlaufen soll ich meiner Seite lang
hier haben und Vulkan
ist aber nichts mit dieser Wolke zu tun
oder naja wir lassen uns nicht wehren ja
also gute Laune hier guck mal hier wird
auch getanz rund um das Maisfeld rum
schön meins haben wir ja auch noch am
Start haben wir hier vorne auch noch
Leute die haben Strand tanzen die Vögel
hier fliegen wieder hoch hier vorne
tanzen alle wieder im Kreis rum hier
sind auch noch irgendwelche Sachen
gelagert hier tanzen sie wieder so Berge
an so schnell
[Musik]
ich kann doch springen oh mein Gott ich
bin ja brutal schnell da wir unsere neue
Geschwindigkeit kennengelernt haben
würde ich sagen sprinten wir jetzt mal
hier vorne den Berg hoch an alle Leute
die hier so ein bisschen tanzen vorbei
und schauen uns mal den Vulkan an da
kann ich jetzt nicht mit allzu viel
Krawall hochlaufen aber wie die Insel
ist schon groß guck mal da da vorne war
das Feld wo wir vorhin waren da unten
Mann Leute am Tanzen das noch Leute auf
dem Berg und hier ist der Vulkan
da wir eh nichts zu tun haben würde ich
sagen mache ich das jetzt einfach mal
also zack hier runter und
[Musik]
ach du kacke
acht okay das tut mir leid ich darf da
ich bin dann mal weg
[Musik]
Leute
[Applaus]
irgendwie so hey komm mit
Popcorn
oh mein Gott
irgendwie krass machen
die schon weg aber
also ein Boot nehmen ist ein bisschen
schlau oder willst du auch nicht
irgendwie von einem attackiert glaube
ich
[Musik]
ciao